all right and we are laughs PAX East
still live day two and day three recap
sorry we missed you guys yesterday a lot
going on but we had to give you some
coverage introduce the Lords of the
realm the most technical broad is in the
building Lord solve what is going on sir
yeah man what's going on man I know it's
late guys and we're all a little nice a
little narrated but hey it it's been an
eventful past two days man I have to say
before anything else big shout out to
the rest of the team man
Lord MJ is the boss Lord pewdie aka
snailed oh of course we need o-katsu
can't dude we were out there hustling
hustling hustling putting in a lot of
work man
it was a great experience I have to say
map packs packs is a fantastic venue it
really is it highlights the smaller
developers at this pax we didn't have a
lot of big develop developer presence
besides the borderlands stuff um you
know when some stuff in PlayStation very
little from from Xbox and Nintendo as
well some new stuff but honestly man the
stars of the show with the Indies yeah
really a lot of Indies you know you know
my switch bias and pretty much every
India that you saw coming down the
pipeline is either on you know on steam
steam were coming the steam and
eventually coming to consoles and of
course the switch so man I gotta say it
really has been a great show absolutely
and of course the incredible Hawken it's
the premium gamer himself lord King how
has your past experience been so far day
two and day three we catch man I told
you what I told you we here right I
explained it to you but you I thought it
was a joke right so now that we got the
podcasts up in the middle of the night
you come off your heads it is in the
streets I didn't understand that we had
to get out here right
all right so like sovereign said shout
out to the whole team the whole squad
and the memory of Lord whiskey the
Hustle is real like Blaine this is this
is a two-seater machine moving there's a
wonder to behold like you see your team
at one end of the spectrum and you at
the other end of the spectrum where you
work in the room when you bring it
across but you also know that you have
faith in your squad cuz they over there
doing the same exact hustle that you
doing and you're bringing it across so
with other developers see your other
side of your team they understand
exactly what the movement is and shout
out to every developer that gave us time
shout out to every developer that
granted us access to their games that
they labored over shout out to every
developer that even went the extra mile
and gave the interviews and we have so
much content and I'm really stressing we
have so much content that these other
frauds in these streets like shake it
back talking about what they heard about
they talked about what they thought
about or what they regurgitating what's
on another website that is not the ILP
websites the Lords of gaming dotnet
because if you want the truth the Lords
are given that medicine to boof so check
there I'm gonna give a shout-out to
wicked gaming's calm oh were shouting
him brother shout out to them brothers
over there shout out to my man that Bob
doesn't mean that's that's me that's
that he this is me he's official me this
is crazy
um shout out to what is it uh pop or
down poppadom shout out the pumping Dom
Oh baby
so it's nothing crazy right and then
they had a sovereign that was missing
and I was sorry
we linked up with those dudes um I'm not
gonna find the energy is dead a love and
a passion for the gaming community is
there and for us to be up this late my
voice is hoarse saying he took all this
video and we bring you this gaming
realness so we are here for you
we're gonna um start off the show after
card s is intro very good stuff that
y'all want to hear about you already
know and you already know the lord of
the cooperative experience himself lord
kognito not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear and you
need to know the Lord's were in the
building in the realm of Pax man so many
faces that we saw so many great games so
many good developers man just passionate
about what they do want to shout a
couple of people out that we always run
into or shout the doc cupcake Inferno
always outdid chopping it up last night
you know you know a shout out to the SDG
see I saw on bear claw out there man
moving I think it shouldn't seem
negative but um we had a lot of friends
that we've seen and everybody's working
and doing anything and it's come up
shout-out to hip-hop gave yours there he
was out here working dude we got some
crazy footage with him as well and um I
just like it's just interesting for me
because it's like packs if you have a
member for and my opinion is a little
bit more of an intimate experience with
the devs and you really get the chance
to dive deep and on first of all salute
to all y'all already like liking the
videos you know I'm saying making the
comments and that's just like a third of
the content that we want to get out
there we we can't even get all the guys
everyone see you guys fast enough we
still working on it put on yeah man it's
been tremendous shout the Fonz
a lot of love and of course you know I'm
saying Lord PD Lawson Aldo MJ the boss
he was out there working hard man just
word man just everybody just coming
together for the team Lords a game and
dotnet putting up the articles superfast
my man dizzy
you already said GaN doors Condor you
know I'm saying we got a lot of things
going and a secret weapon that shall be
named propia
time
for that but only that yo before I
ramble cuz I'm a little nice but today's
today's war today
I gotta cool out yesterday cut King
accuse me of me in to saucy for the
podcast side to cool out today outside
to Jake my water you don't saying slow
down a little bit there will be no trash
segments today daddy - Ophir toes live
right now your photo was so lit man we
had so much yo shout-out to a sir cuz I
don't know what y'all doing but Cooley
y'all business line is really moving out
here with the predator product zoo
sausage shout out shout out the ace of
forgiving you that Cali filled with the
twitch party move worm died out to ASA
for having that crowd jumping how to
pack a party and have them lines around
the block face I wanted to be like those
dudes like if you was outside envious to
be inside he had a reason to be envious
because it was crazy in there if you
didn't get inside with sucks to be you
yeah it was vicious out there with
vicious man even saw you felt the wrath
man yeah I was not privy to the VIP
benefits so I decided to arrive later
and that was a mistake
by the time I got there which was like I
got there about nine twenty nine twenty
five literally the line was the entire
length of the it was the entire length
of Fenway Park let's see the crazy part
about that is mmm had sovereign listen
to the king he would have been in the
building and I told her we leaving right
now
so to journalists now I'm gonna get down
flex pay no Ally my bro just oh follow
me - gasping no
okay so he want to be fashionably he
want to pull the Beyonce I was nice move
man got out that a predator ban but we
go do it real quick because like we like
it's been two days we missed you guys
yesterday it's been a lot of good games
a lot of coverage born distracted it's
they asking where is Lord shank already
that do have me locked up in the trunk I
had to jump about that broad
I had to duck that dude out yo he might
make an appearance
probably on IOP sometime soon I don't
know the dude is unpredictable
nah I'm looking over my shoulders I
don't even know how he got the jump on
me to be honest with you the gear box
crew there but yo go do it day two and
day three recap so I'm just like what's
the standouts for you guys what are some
of the games that you know we kind of
touched and we want to give it to the
people as far as like top three toughly
yeah I get top three like what's your
personal top three let's give it to you
King let's get you jump in first
alright you're not saying yeah that you
like imma start off with three right I'm
a starter for three and three is a
combination of love it's a combination
of the dev being there willing to
produce and give his oil all to the
interview as a combination it's a whole
conglomerate of things that push this
game so to make it to my top three now
my friends I'm telling you when I'm
saying that we have so much content and
we've seen so many games and this is not
a slight on any developer any interview
any game that we've seen but this is not
three in my opinion and it can vary from
person to person but we're gonna have so
much content for you to pick and choose
your best but my first in my top three
tomorrow my third counting down it's
losing chrome so what's what's blaze do
chrome break it down for the people who
don't know what blazing chrome is you
see that snap that right there and
actually get into that and actually see
that game catch that b-roll footage all
right whoa blazing chrome is the
spiritual successor to
contra hardcore that was for the Genesis
the game looks amazing the developer
explaining that he's waited for years
and years for a true successor to contra
and Nomura Coraline and it never came so
you know stager wasn't willing to step
forward nobody was willing to step
forward to make this game this guy's
made it in true fashion mmm exactly the
same like it was just a year like even
with the filters the game looked and
played and control just like contra
hardcore like contra hardcore - it was
even explained that we purposely did not
use polygons we purposely did not use
any advanced tools we use retro tools
for making his game Wow everything they
even use mode 7 for the scaling Brian
he said they they delve deep into what
may contra hardcores great and decided
that this is the game that they wanted
to make and it gave them all and Twitter
shoutout to that developer which is a
toy master that's Joey
we spoke to we interviewed Danny low
which is one half of the development
team so you're looking at a two-person
team working on this game for something
like upwards of three years like wow so
small team
yeah these small devs these small
developers like literally that you're
not really it's hard to even call them
like a hug the relative really like
family like it really is just one or two
people it's like a development duel
exactly it's only my second mask
assemblance break that damn break that
dad game is like like what is it what's
the gay like landstalker
Bastion mm-hmm
it's an action RPG type of game but as a
couch co-op it was so much going on into
it because sovereign was doing an
interview and I was so captivated by the
game but it develop out about our
direction
they said that that game could be either
played from the end boss or the
beginning and he gave the whole spiel on
how that dynamic changes how the game
turns out I was I was struck by so much
passion that was put into this game not
out to mask a semblance okay what's the
number one skull boy whoa
switch what say that again
switch I'm gonna tell you guys right now
if you got a switch you've been holding
it in your pocket and you ain't been
buying anything get ready to get that
big account scorched because go in
further go a little you say King no you
know what the funny thing is infernal if
I have my fraud alert right now right
now Ferno was in the same place that I
was and he knows how heavy switch is
moving like switches moving in such a
pace they got a game that didn't even
make my top three that she will make
everybody's top three but [ __ ] I made my
top three but these games are such a
standout that if you purchased them
you're not gonna be upset with me that
switch game there's one and they know
what I'm talking about
hopefully one of these guys to speak and
pick it up he's running at 60 frames per
second I've never seen any such game
running at 60 frames per second what was
going on and we got the footage we don't
only ones with that footage so that
means we'll be seen like we roasted ones
that got it this and we don't only ones
they got it because you know why the
only way you had to get it is if you was
in deep with the dev and we are deep
with that check it out let's solve it no
solvent so gonna probably put that game
he's gonna probably put her on blast I'm
a step away from this because the last
game I said it's skull boy which has the
greatest art direction of any swimming
take Dave Graham Wow hold on a second we
gotta give a shout out my boy I saw him
up I believe it was arm Anthony
we are just about justice it's coming oh
there he is Edna Karr he said hey man
can I get a shoutout
he said to duncan mccoy Turner hope you
guys are doing well Saluja
you already know the Lord's gonna give
it up man much appreciate it so long
yeah King with that the hot selection
you don't understand that's what's up
and oh hold on the other person who must
have ran bina 8127 went Thursday but
wish I got to run into y'all austin show
this year that is what's up so um yeah
people are shocked with your selections
King you know I'm saying but that's
what's up so Lord saw he was out here
moving and shaking I've seen interview
skills sharpening out well I was just so
happy to have you out there man people
know who you are because I know how
talented you are so it's good to see so
what are your absolutely what about what
are your standouts like what's the
things right now for you three gains off
top Lord sovereign standouts
I'm gonna tell you right now I'm gonna
cheat a little bit I'm gonna I'm gonna
package some games together but I'll
give them a couple of solos so uh so
first off mom I have to go with the guys
over at area 35 and tiny metal guys
these are these are the guys that made
the original tiny metal which is a
spiritual successor to Advance Wars um
oh wow right and they're making a sequel
to tiny metal which is called a tiny
metal full metal Rumble this game again
like if you like the first tiny metal
and all the cues that it took from the
original Advance Wars again I think the
one thing that we got from all of these
developers these smaller developers that
are making these spiritual successors
and love letters to older games that we
love is the fact that it's saying you
know what these the big three are not
making these games anymore don't know
why they're not so you know what we're
gonna make it and I don't care if it's a
two-man team a one-man team five-man
team these guys are doing some amazing
things so shout out to the guys at area
35 tiny metal looks absolutely fantastic
we'll have a sermon on this part
being for that game for that switch game
and mmm I think he was the CEO who came
out of the back and he had interview
that he had with another media or
platform but I pressed to his stand guys
I was standing there playing I said no
no I need somebody to talk about this
game if you're not gonna give me the
interview that's fine but I want to get
the interview this game and I want this
game to be shown they brought the CEO
out of the back and he gave us time gave
us a press kit gave us a beer wolf he
gave us everything we basically wanted
about this game and I was so happy
because I told him that this game was
exactly what I wanted for my switch so
another which game that I champion for
that I saw that said just had to be
highlighted I just wanted to set that
out there that y'all guys think I don't
like to switch no yes will you not using
you're not using it portable Fonzarelli
love yo you gotta be feeling I was
feeling real good maybe give me some
real positive encouragement
thank you brother all mad definitely
love but continue man what's going you
go inferno and say who is this and what
did you do with King with this switch
law shank without the mask that's all if
shake without the bench
well my bandsaw you got to finish up so
you got ya don't you for join
so my second game is a game that King
saw as we were on our way to lunch
we stopped by these guys booth at King
said oh listen guys we're going to lunch
we're gonna recharge the batteries when
we come back we're coming right to you
oh so big shout out to the guys at decoy
games okay there came swim sanity these
guys that sound that sound what's going
what's going on with that
basically it's an underwater aquatic
combat game that can be played in versus
mode it can be played in single-player
can be played in multiplayer
when you first look at this game the
game looks like a simple little
multiplayer couch co-op not even called
couch vs. play game
we sat when we stopped and talked to
these guys and interviewed them this
game is so deep it has them versus
multiplayer it has the co-op multiplayer
it has a full-on story mode it has like
eight different modes of play one of
which I believe is about Aurora mode as
well it is in terms of art style
everything in terms of the story of this
development group these are three guys
two brothers a big shout-out to Ahmed to
Khalil - Chris okay salut these guys
have a story that mirrors our own
basically like these guys obviously the
two brothers and Chris they all grew up
together love and go complain video
games and they said basically like nine
years ago we decided man we want to make
games how do we go about doing this they
went about they did everything they
needed to do to educate themselves in
terms of games Chris was already an
artist they they came back to Chris to
try to figure out the art style for her
first whim Sam shout out to these guys
these guys it is such a grassroots sort
of movement with this with decoy games
and I was just so heartened to see
somebody they had a story that resembled
our own at ILP
it was really great to see how this is
so what something really want to tell
you is that was his greatest interview
[Applause]
let me tell you so you know if y'all
want to see the verbal gymnastics set
forth by my master ninjas sovereign
himself who ever was so nimble with
their with the widow with the verbage he
was just hitting him with a bang bang
boogie likes jagged up in the middle
like and then he he switched off to the
next dude a you know I'm gonna tell you
if many of you guys want to learn how to
give an interview check out sovereigns
interview
there were these that this man displayed
I was standing there I was in the back
on the camera like that's my I'm trying
to tell y'all I could run this right
here man solve confronting this like I
don't even know you're there like so
it's good to see him in his bag you know
me doing this thing and I can't wait
just a lot of this stuff I haven't seen
cuz like I said we split up into teams
we're is out there covering stuff shout
out to infertile shout dyadic to the
chat we miss you bro you got to get back
out here man you already know shout out
to inferno furnace na no offense at all
but Lord South man this is the hardest
I've ever seen you go oh man I gotta
tell you man like it's been difficult
for me to get out to shows and these
guys have been hustling and working so
the thing is this year I said I have to
go to everything especially last year I
felt so bad that you know my presence
which was needed just just on the night
we needed bodies here I wasn't able to
help I said no that at all so and when
when cog decided this year listen we're
gonna split off in the team that we're
really gonna attack this show floor and
he told me I didn't even I didn't know
what my role was gonna be he says no
you're interviewing so I mean like all
all props go to King and go to COG for
having that faith in me and and just
pushing me out there um you guys are
gonna see man this there was a couple of
ones that a little nerve-wracking you
forget something here there but as time
goes on you get a little more
comfortable and you just kind of be a
little more comfortable in your own skin
you know when you just act listen listen
assess is faking Security's popular let
me tell you something I said you know
you see none of that stuff that he's
talking about right there
see and all that is in his mind yeah
when you see it you gonna understand
what I'm talking about you'll understand
you guys say okay y'all see the reason
why you go see I see what time it is so
that's what's up so you got those two
you got this one said that you got one
more song but you got like I said I'm
cheating and I'm gonna group these guys
know we're gonna do that
due next we need to talk about it now I
hate you can give an honorable mention
at the end unless you're gonna mention
them at cognate don't give it up giggle
one give it a lot of these dudes I
decided not to and I know they're
looking at me like and they probably in
a chat like just do the sitting because
my game is fired yes your game is fired
I'm telling you every game that we saw
the reason why we stopped at your booth
is because we felt your energy the
reason why I stopped at your booth is
because your game displayed what our
platform decides to show which is great
content I felt that your stuff stood up
to aisle P standard no point in time
there's any game fall beneath that but
what we're trying to say is these are
the gold stars these are the best of the
best so there's gonna be a top three
we're gonna do the top five top five
Dead Alive but its top three there's no
rules baby so hungee brothers okay okay
so I will pick one from this group and
we'll talk more later but I have to pick
wrath Aeon of ruin from our guys at once
we publish things and 3d realms this is
an O in the classic vein of quake it is
actually in the quake engine this game
like a dream guys are masters at taking
everything that you love about those
classic FPS and the ones that started
the ball I started at all the
granddaddies of this genre and in fact
it and and the people working on these
games mind you it's not just people that
that that love these games and it's a
love letter to them the people working
on this games have ax actually worked on
these on Duke Nukem on quake things of
that nature so it's not like it's just a
love letter to this stuff these guys
have worked on this for years and
they've taken that weekend and it is now
thirty some-odd your engine
the gate the engine runs so smoothly
that he said listen the the game is
running at 60 on every single console
including the switch including this way
ah and it's running they have it you
know since it's about like held and
demons and whatnot so he said yeah you
know we capped the framerate we capped
it at 666 frames per second you know six
didn't hold on one second so we gotta
pay the bill you'll shout out to our
brother Jay Fonzarelli with the Train
dollar super chat he said y'all share a
bottle or me Lords I know it's probably
$10 for one out there they could did
yeah it's $10 for real
but I'm bottles and them francs and them
hot dogs for real he said I appreciate
everything I do
that's the game were there you go shout
the slow-mo in the chassis you clean but
in a brother 60 FPS at 280 no fines I'm
gonna honestly tell you there's two
games in it it's on a switch right I
mean it not even talking from from this
one developer and sovereign no this is
what sovereigns laughing all right you
have no idea what's coming brother I'm
telling you it is 720p to nine hundred P
60 frames per second nobody is doing it
I don't know what secret sauce they got
in them but I just well the Xbox version
I saw the PlayStation version and let's
sort of switch version and I'm honestly
gonna tell you the only thing different
is a little bit of resolution and the
game is matching payslip pace slows whoa
whoa nuts you know I'm gonna be honest
with you man everything that we saw it
feels like if there's any truth to these
rumors about these to switch models
coming out one being more powerful Wow
we saw is indicative of of that like
like as if these devs know something
they're trying to put stuff on this
and putting it on there with success so
glad we're looking at it like nah that's
not no no no way mmm so pretty much what
you're saying is in comparison in the
past cuz you guys saw more switch tough
demeanor [ __ ] this year I haven't got a
chance to touch a lot of switched off or
do lots with coverage so in your opinion
you're saying the graphical fidelity of
the switch games have really closed the
gap so almost inferring that possibly
switch Pro kits maybe in the wild are
that we inferring yeah I'm definitely
inferring that cuz I'll tell you right
now they see in past shows you look at
the indie stuff and not all of it is
necessarily is fine I was back MJ you
want to beat you so bad like your hero
where's Eddie he's like how tall is he
how you see the man I'm like he's not as
tall as kick he's not too big but he's
my guy so you say every indie game that
we saw there for the most for a lot of
times the first step is obviously steam
that's where they go to first for the
most part everybody said yeah coming to
switch coming is every single thing that
we saw coming this witness wait to come
in the switch so any some of the stuff
we're like really you're kidding right
possible do an interview right we talked
about this game like we have a switch
demo up right now I turn it is dude
[Laughter]
turning him to say oh you know that's
happening
you're gonna show that game they got a
special dude out the bushes yo I'm gonna
tell you right now he said I could play
it or you could play it I said listen
listen you know about the game you gonna
show it in as best like all I just want
to do is just capture the footage he
started it I said this is why my I cash
we app right there I woulda hit the cash
yet right there shout inferno he said
they realize how much the switch is
still selling these devs will do
whatever it is to get it on a platform
he said I can't tell you how many times
dad's told me switch in PC and I said
okay switch there yo facts facts that
that's a serious three solve like that
and that's again I I was cheated by King
yo now when I'm glad you mentioned 1c
because um we were talking about them
before and shout out the one Siena team
because like I don't know what it is
with that studio who's scouting okay the
go thro King once T entertainment this
is two packs in a row they are my top
development like they all my top
well-being bulbs publisher their
published excuse me and um yo they got
an eye for talent bro 1c and it's a man
salut another fantastic yeah I cannot
wait to see the footage that saw has
going over there I got a chance to see
them last year solved in it this year
cannot wait man I'm gonna jump into mind
real quick I think for me it's pretty
obvious I mean from the third one right
now yeah I didn't get a chance to see
the footage yet but um it's this it's
this game it's so simple but it's
hilarious and our style fun it's called
one Finger Death Punch there's a sequel
yo this game it looks like a kung foo
like hangman game like the stick figures
and stuff like that and it though the
game II are style it's like the essence
of Shaolin I got a great interview with
the dev we're gonna get into he is truly
a love letter to the conflicts and all I
could
stuff from back in the day but again
it's just a cool art style you're gonna
talk about the platform's it's coming to
is also coming to switch an Xbox really
really cool game so that's on my list
that's number three number to stop the
Cognito for stealing that game for me
tell you right now we was walking past
is twice we walk past muse altogether I
said oh and they snap so I was like oh
snap right there's definitely what does
do so we walk past again and I happen to
had carved with me so he actually
poached this one and I was like yo you
already know King like that's how joint
if you grew up with them kung-fu flicks
than Bruce Lee joins them Jackie Chan
joints you know I'm saying them run run
Shaw joints it is it's simplistic but
it's fun and it's vicious it's all made
so much I could go with I'm not you
gonna see hitter view with that dev and
he's passionate bro like you're gonna
love it I cannot wait you guys to see
that one so that's all number three
number two yeah I've already seen
already I have it up we're gonna do a
three-part series is gays god I have to
give it up man days gone really
impressed me
oh hi Liam yeah man like impressed with
Sony on that one they change the
direction but I like what's going on
right now game looks graphically better
they added more cinematics yeah I'm
digging the vibe right now from them so
that's number two number two because
number three kabocha came in here and
told me we got 24 people that's in this
chat and I'm doing this from my phone so
I'll see what y'all pulling over there
what happened
[Laughter]
shout that nobody's like interview was
good but still not my cup of tea I feel
you over it's not for everybody but I
think what what sets it apart day's
going so number three it was was the one
punch joint number the one punch console
he said day's going is not his time for
a cup of tea yes I want you to
understand this right and and I'm gonna
be honest with you if you ever respect
anything that I'm gonna tell you I want
you to be on and I'm gonna be honest
with you first of all I play on
everything mm-hmm and now game was
always the game that I was looking at
even when it looked a little dish nice
sword a game live footage and said oh I
was on one interview and looked over at
it from the periphery of my eye and
looked over at Cog as he did the
interviewer said oh my god oh I can't
front on it like graphically
I'm saying now I know y'all was in them
comment sections talking about
checkerboard and whatever I don't kill
what is checkerboard that it looked good
for change all the world look fantastic
you know and I'm saying if I had to
nitpick I was saying maybe when he was
on the bike you know I'm saying like the
frame a little bit hey like what a whole
bunch of zombies but it was so many
characters on screen you're gonna mean
so shut up today I'm shout the Benz
studio y'all it's looking good I'm
excited I want to see more about it I
love the different mechanics than just a
standard zombie game and I can get my
son's an archaeon so shout out the day's
going bang studios number two number one
you already know what it is I already
know what it is
Klan to claw Axl please space ragebaby
what that Streets of Rage let me tell
you I came in with very low expectations
I'm like alright you know is this gonna
be the cash grab you don't say like is
it gonna be are they really going to
take it in and I'm gonna tell you all
right now I know it's early but it's in
good hands
the
the devs that I wanted and shout out to
um damn I thought mo and it's like a
three parts are a little dev team
because you got dumb you got Lizzie cube
and I forgot to get God crush card crush
game yeah it's dumb three it's like a
little trifecta on this man and these
are guys that came from wonderboy rice
off you know some one of them came from
wonder boy
the only one boy the Dragons trapped the
the remake bro
I'm trying to get that footage for your
Lord trust me my GoPro ready to RZA
trying I was trying to sneak to I'll try
but is like now shut that down brother
ah got more commonly don't get me wrong
but I'm not your Streets of Rage for let
me tell you out right now the cell shake
in one of the our guys he's like he did
comics right so his art style you know
what I knew the game was lit when the
goons was fired
cool your day had two dudes with their
hands in the pockets like where you go
over posh okay like that y'all let tell
you right now the goons is art styles is
just as good as to me for tagging yeah
so they got it they got the feel now
right now they still mixing it up with
the beats how they go and do it
because they got those beats no beeps
off I see the SS eries anybody Streets
of Rage fan know you gotta had a good
game play Tuco out the moves all that
but the beats they had good backs that's
when we knew the Genesis sound trip at
that time yeah exactly so as a Sega kid
I'm gonna shine in the blast process
although good say streets arrangement yo
the beats everything now a lot of stuff
right now
real talk a reason why they don't want
to show a lot of stuff right now is
placeholder I mean the game is running
don't get me wrong but a lot of stuff is
still subject to change so they want to
commit to everything but from what we're
hearing again you already see the
interviews up right now it's on ILP go
check that out you know I'm saying we
got some great talks with them they are
really going for the SS apparently some
returning characters she'll be coming
back I hope shorty with the skate come
back with the back no sure sure my big
boy so we'll see you but they said they
want to do a bit of a homage to the old
and also some new stuff they don't want
it to be just old stuff you know I'm
saying and I gotta feel them so shout
out to these guys please support them we
definitely working on cooking up some
things
when I appear and I'm in the future but
trees of rage for the pure excitement
nostalgia they've hit the tone now we
just got to see them follow it through
everything that I've seen everything I
touch MJ the boys got a chance to play
it so now they got a chance to play he
was getting busy they got super moves
and super moves so lit like it all like
little mechanics that you get used to
get annoying intrusive remember we like
you hit somebody or you do your special
it would take energy they got rid of
that they got different locales they got
a Joey fighting in the train station but
you can't jump and is packed up with the
girls north is fine I mean I'm telling
any art style the cel-shaded just the
less they killing it right now so full
support oh now I can't wait to see what
the brothers do on that one man so
that's about three right there so it's
like I said the one punch one punch
joint day's going
streets rage for that's my three all
right so now I'm gonna give you a recap
guys just go to her door which I didn't
understand was 18 was on the big squad
there was on them big there was on them
blockbusters you understand them
diehards there was hitting them you know
hard to kill type of game it was putting
that out the park you know I'm saying in
Robocop's
and I we was out here
we was born the minute you know Jim's in
the bushes and let me tell you something
man we rattled those bushes we shipped
those trees and got down to everything
that y'all wanted to see and I honestly
I'm gonna tell you this you know this
this is no disrespect to anybody that's
out there regurgitating information haha
you heard that no don't disrespect Eazy
with the e per track tonight no
disrespect for the for those dudes
regurgitating stuff that they thought
they heard that they thought they saw
but I'm gonna tell you man we do this
because we love we love video games
thanks and on this pack floor for you
guys that's in these chats that's in
these Twitter streets that's all these
little airwaves that is sitting here
talking about game system versus system
yeah none of that is present in these
game conferences facts I saw a guy with
an xbox shirt with an Xbox hat on a
playstation line
I saw PlayStation guy playing Forza with
a whole PlayStation getup
I want to understand you being a slave
to a piece of plastic and pledging
allegiance to a fake narrative that
doesn't exist outside of your little box
is redundant and the and actually
nonsensical I was going to use a word
that people get me but I just got had to
change that let me tell you something
IOP Lords of game and dotnet the
movement is pure gaming having a
character gaming and that's all we got
we saw people dressing up we saw people
from every walks of life we saw them
from every corner of this planet in one
place to do one thing you play games and
to know more about the games they learn
learn and I'm tweeting that hate and get
back to the guernseyman power let's get
to it
pax is really a celebration of games
like it really really is even more so
like that then III honestly just because
III it's just so difficult you focus on
the big three you focus on a lot of
triple-a stuff when you talk about a
true celebration of everything that is
gaming including the triple-a stuff and
the smaller stuff it's really it really
is packs yeah man I'm glad you said
listen it's your first one so so it's
like it's good to see you know in the
mix and see they actually say that
because I always felt the same way like
it's no disrespect to III I just look at
it like III is the Super Bowl you know
I'm saying but like pax is like getting
busy in training camp you're going
through the season you're starting to
see the genesis of certain things right
yeah mm-hmm
the lifeblood is packs like their organs
but the blood that pumps us that keeps
us moving has got panic attacks tell me
I want to shout out golden I want to
shout out Inferno keys like your ass cog
who told him pax is better to eat than
forgive me listen I don't I I know what
I personally like because both have that
place like does not get it twisted like
III press conference when you had a
press conference whoa and Phil she's
like there's a certain energy that's why
I say super good right cuz it Super Bowl
we're boy boys play with the big boys
playing you start to see iconic people
and you just pass you know Corey Borlaug
and the passing this one in you look
it's crazy it's [ __ ] star shock star
power it's like the Oscars whatever you
want to call its death like packs though
again it's just grass roots from the
core it you know what it almost reminded
think I'll use an example of force like
it's like you're getting to see who your
favorite artist or celebrity is they
just start now right so it's like yo
listen to my mixtape you know they're
like here's my here's my demo and they
so eager they just want someone you know
I'm gonna tell you
i'ma tell you how that is so fact thick
factual and this is not fiction actually
he's speaking true facts shout-out to
warhorse studios well shout out the
world on the ring nor Dobby listen no
let me let me explain let me give you a
Genesis real quick and how I will
platform actually realizing soil
greatness and stood up for greatness and
and I told him and I honor and I
personally had a chance to tell Sir Eric
his face rich in space that I felt
elated in my heart when I heard you got
purchase bag THQ Nordic and we sat there
when Sean uh system checks is a bit
different right that's a very different
but you know who didn't change he didn't
change yeah yes he still no he hit us at
that same night to go to this to the
next party to go to the next situation
let me shout out to warhorse Studios for
being the realest people in the game
they kept at a 100 with ILP from day one
and never stop never changed never got
Hollywood never did nothing different
and it's still willing to come on to the
show and gave us that personal interview
with the new dr the interview in the
gameplay that you're gonna see i
personally would like to say thank you
1% from my heart and i'm so happy that
we I got one more guys grow I got one
more I'm so glad you said that too
because for me personally I gonna see
the footage when I put up is shout out
to sabotage studios and the messenger
because I remember was soft put me on
and soft tells me about the game last
three I mean last packs before packs and
he's like your cop ninja game about this
is you I said I cool I said I say yes
Salvage right this this is crazy and
this CD that progression and he had the
small old modest blue flashing on saying
my boy shoutout to the
we shout out to the team a you see the
growth and then as the year went on
maybe the reception grew chance my boy
meds Erica erica for the air cuts for
the wind a lot of people that rep the
game and I'm saying obviously come out
to everybody and like Jen remember the
game Awards came up yes and they snagged
it like the best dude in the other
biggest stage they'd be out some heavy
hitters so like when I seen him mad like
it was crazy I got the new DLC dropping
we gonna get into that you don't see
that footage gonna go up so but like I
see the air and he had the same and if
he was like yo kognito shaloo understand
that you had that passion for what he
had facts like cuz it again it's these
guys dreams right it's literally this is
their sales pitch this is listen to my
demo listen to my mixtape you know I'm
saying and you come over and you know I
like what you're spitting over this okay
go say I'm a rock with this and and to
see that growth and I told them I said
I'm so proud of you guys
like to see that development to see that
accolade on the biggest stage the game
Awards where you got the gig you know
the heavy hitters got awards and redness
we get that but you know saying the
little guys get out there and they shine
and just like that social oops sabotage
studio the message of that one's coming
I'm very proud of that one because if
you go see the love you show like I was
fully cuz it's very organic you know I'm
saying you know yeah man that's what
PACs is about if you haven't been so in
that same vein the guys at motion twin
and dead cells really I mean that game
is amazing as it is are the fact that
they're adding more bosses that was a
new dlc the the rise of the giant um
honestly man that game is in terms of
like mechanics it that that game is as
close to perfection as you get
everything is so tight and and you know
that the whole rogue vania thing where
you're constantly repeating stuff and
whatnot they really again they've taken
that game to another level they said
they're gonna continue to be working on
it and they also started out some new
stuff too so hopefully and next packs or
maybe before them we were able to see
what the next stuff next game is that
they're working on but really and the
work that they did on dead cells and
they continue to do on dead cells it's
freaking ridiculous man yeah shadows
doings bad but yeah I mean that that's
that's what I got man you know another
successful pax in the books we might do
some cleanup tomorrow there's a lot of
stuff maybe that the Lord's want to
finish out what I know the boss is out
there moving for us to you know saying
shout the PT as well but I've been
really enjoy it's been really cool I
can't wait to get a lot of this stuff
you guys to see it can you got anything
else for the people day two and day
three combo recap what I want to tell
you guys is i'ma tell you this um being
the marketing director for ILP um a lot
of times you know guys are tired guys
are sleepy look at his finger when he
pointing to himself because his dead
serious a lot of these guys are they
work they self to the bone
alright I gave sovereign Blum some stuff
to to help with his feet the other day
well good to that backs floor life my VI
dumb one gains them he'll he was on his
feet eight to ten hours and to to do
this is not easy so I can see why a lot
of you guys sit in your house and
regurgitate information but this is not
what ILP is about when I know it sounds
like I'm giving an indictment to you
guys know I'm giving you a warning
because it's up its up its up up you
know cuz these guys think they always
keep me in line and I'm nice right now
so in saying this I'm telling you and
I'm letting you know I LP will
constantly keep that foot on your neck
and we will constantly keep bringing you
the greatest content that you can ever
get because we're gonna constantly get
to these shows when we got a car
certainly get greater and greater
content and no matter what we're going
to push pure gaming forward we're going
to push this cut this community together
we're not gonna push a separatist agenda
we're pushing everybody to get together
will constantly be in a place where
seldom people want to go we're gonna
break out of this comfort zone and we're
gonna make sure that we're part of this
entertainment movement thanks understand
we are here for you so tomorrow I might
not want to get up I might not want to
get out of my bed but I will get out of
my bed I will rise out of that bed like
Tyson Fury from that night I'm gonna
walk into that pax and even if I got to
give you a damn run through I pay good
money to make sure I give you a run or
I'm gonna give you that run through and
you're gonna see that smooth pax
experience because if you at home if
you're if you're disabled treat your
legs
if you can't see I'm gonna make sure
that I'm your eyes if you can't feel I'm
gonna beat your hands I'm gonna make
sure that I'm on that pax floor for you
so then III don't underst I don't
understand how people are out here
trying to separate separate us mm-hmm
but I'm not trying to pull us together
so I love each and every last one of us
gamers because we don't love the same
exact thing so shout out to the whole
team that is here that is sacrificing
because even if they taken time off from
work time off from school time off on
family they're taking time off from
something else to bring you content to
help you and entertain you and that you
can further in this please respect that
no doubt shout out to kidding with data
back to back freestyle infrared all that
you know I'm saying like he's out here
he's moved up a free style as well you
go all the drinks again everybody was in
it boots is on the neck now the real son
I feel he's saying it's just like look
at the end of the day like y'all know
this come from the heart you know I'm
saying like y'all know we do this for
y'all y'all energize us we see the
retweets we seal the love it a really
fuels us to keep
on this thing man and to see the growth
in the progression and see solve out
here moving forward secret weapon got a
fake on issue in love tonight man yo
shout out to Philip all our boys at e3
20 2003 3 absolutely come check us out
brother absolutely approach say hi take
a pic with the Lords you know we love
that stuff but continues ah man your
first pax in the books it been
absolutely fantastic I have to say like
again like the the lack of the big three
presence notwithstanding I mean that
this to me was an indie show and I think
we need that I think people need to
remember we're like remember the small
games remember it takes us back to the
roots of hardcore gaming and just basic
things like like running gun like
basically all of those things that are
sort of lost in these big triple a
multi-million dollar games those core
concepts are all alive and well and
present in all of these smaller games
and the fact that they they're all these
guys are working so hard just to get
there and get a booth and they're so
eager to show you their game and talk
about that game it is such an amazing
experience if you're a fan if you're
somebody going there to do coverage
whatever the case may be if you go there
and you are a lover of video games
you're gonna come out smile on your face
no matter if you're on your feet an hour
a 10 hours it doesn't know what's going
oh I got it I gotta say this I gotta see
this
and I ever don't I don't ever want to
interrupt my brother let's go start out
to think gotta do that you gotta do this
is what we closed down but I gotta do
that something I'm gonna tell you
something I'm working on something so
hard right now with these I think e
geek with the love that they show to the
king man y'all let me thinking if you're
watching this and I'm a hashtag y'all
and this right here if you are watching
this you have set a fire under the king
that which has never been seen
yes'm let me tell you I got song coming
for you guys you go save I know you got
save ego save you go say I know what you
doing I know what you do it's gonna be
listen yeah that your shoutout salute
thinking obviously you know a lot is
coming a lot of love and we definitely
appreciate it and again that get salute
everybody ready to man everybody just
show love out the OL attack you know it
shout out to the devs or I gonna put her
body out the ik solver
shout to the devs that we encountered
that were nervous oh well like yo thank
y'all
you know seeing like that mid for me for
out of respect us on that level like yo
I was loved man that's all I got we got
abs they were like looks
there were devs that came up to us they
actually didn't do interviews and they
had their PR person come up to us but
they stood there they said listen I'm
not comfortable in my language
I'm not comfortable just being a camera
but thank you so much for loving her
game and they stole big it all made
Fredo's in the building y'all talking
ability oh I try to keep that goodness
love now Kratos I already sees that
takes all the interviews updates on the
games bro yeah I brought the big stuff
that's what I wanted to know y'all
appreciate you bro I went in there yo I
gave I gave it up Kratos I said been
stood up for me that was my number two I
want on my top three told for sure man
like y'all got one I'm behind that one
yeah guy I don't know about the
PlayStation community I got to get
behind that I like I don't know it seems
like I get but I like what what I'm
gonna tell you is I think that might be
my game to finish off and I'm usually
you already know I said God a wall his
second fiddle to spider-man all right
and I'm gonna tell you and and everybody
in their heart of hearts understand that
God of War play second fiddle and the
only reason why you know it plays like a
DLC it puts it at a head and shoulders
above because I can continue to play
where you don't but I'm going to say
days gone if you didn't if you own a
Playstation and you didn't give it a
look
I hope to have a demo so you can get it
a look because Cognito knocks it out
thank you brother
oh man it was such a treat also shot the
MJ the boss on the gameplay cuz I'm
gonna tell you right now that horde yo
y'all don't want to smoke with the mods
now I want those smoke with the boys bro
if you ever doubted that game from a
graphical perspective
the Horde coming at you and you see
every single one of those freaker's o
animators coming at you dude
that I mean they raised they really did
a great job with that game crazy yeah
it's crazy but the mechanics is crafting
I'm gonna try to get our part three the
final part will be up probably get that
to you tomorrow morning soon as I say
about 8:00 a.m. 8:00 a.m. Eastern will
get part three up the final part MJ the
boss smiled on the camera and like I
said been studios they show so much love
to get us the behind the scenes
Yoshio it heads BBQ in the chest slow
y'all it's love tonight yeah I came out
to show some love thank you guys yeah
thank you surreal that's all we got
probably not gonna be no IOP tomorrow
cuz we all gonna be hittin it and then
after maybe briefly check out some stuff
get some more footage and hit the road
everybody's gotta get back to their
respective like salute Izzy with the
banhammer - that was fantastic yo shout
again shout but a trifling dude that
night
completely shut out videos everybody
have a good [ __ ] I got let's get
these out chills Lord King
waking the farm people find you what is
going on boys you sort of king of the
statues whoo you sorta Hulk vs.
Wolverine you shagging are vs. Wolverine
for mine speedos who has put it out
there for you like that how much is that
statue 650 cash bro what's really
quickly to go you ready to play in these
arenas that the king let me tell you
something I got a statue that's $3,000
hold him back for you guys and then if
you don't if you don't get all that king
of statues Oh first of all that's my
disclaimer you gotta stop yeah I gotta
be giving these views to these these
tweets that King do him a giant going to
the video and I'm upset a lot I got I
got a tour I gotta talk from doing the
rent now I gotta do my back-to-back
freestyle yeah out there the man put out
the tweets y'all of any statues but I'm
seeing 3,000 views on the tweets but
like a hundred views on it on the video
please hit the video hit the link you
know I'm keep doing too much giving out
all that that just me personally in the
tweet and I'm trying to tell I didn't
get a chance to promo this week right
alright so let me tell you something if
you thought you saw the statue in a
tweet your freaking didn't if you follow
the link and you actually look at the
YouTube video thank you you're really
gonna see the statue on all its glory
and here's a good story and you're
cheating yourself out one of the best
beats ever like King statue beat I'm so
mad I'm not yo I want that for I know so
just off GP click the link for king of
statues for the beat you gonna be
sitting there he salty because he's he
he saw me say you
IOP I got something for you all right
listeners listen Oh awesome Real Talk I
got I got I are king of statues I'm
coming this week I got something that's
gonna knock your speakers socks off
listen I'm gonna make you get up and
tell your wife your girlfriend your
husband I'm gonna make you get up and
tell your boyfriend I'm collecting the
day today I'm actively activating your
envying your jealousy shot the kick
making everybody feel small out here
evading that energy that knows we're all
collectives why cuz you're collecting
these games so I'm gonna put you in a
mind frame when up no guys next joint
this is negatory I'm gonna put out me
later if you don't stand up and smack
the hell out of the dude right listen I
got something else shout out that uh to
think geek yes sir for putting a fire
under the king
yeah I won't say but let's go on he said
he shouldn't be giving it up he said dig
dig been on it man what did you bring up
for it they please I don't gave me four
days in a situation he's in this about
it listen I'm trying to partner with
thinking mm-hmm I got something that's
coming to my house blown in from Spain
on Monday all right and when when it
flies in I'm gonna do an unboxing when a
do or rival I got to talk to the to the
DHL guy and make sure that he's
comfortable with being on camera but I
got it coming in and when this thing
comes in all you guys that were out
there perpetrating the fraud this is
that old sweet you heard what I just
said I saw packaging all right I'm gonna
make sure scope aesthetic I'm using old
language from New York City old slang
I'm gonna make sure that it's copacetic
with the rest of the community when I
put this out yo the shockwaves is gonna
be so billion your king is definitely
his bag right now cuz I'm using a
fertile Sandman bag you gotta bring it
now definitely the truth is not for
Daisy listen when I'm telling you this
when I'm bringing to see you nobody know
where nobody's going or no platform was
going to be able to touch what I'm
bringing you and all right bring it to
you in such a fashion that you're gonna
look over to the person to say this dude
is on his ish and I got a hit on the ish
that he's on and trust me the viewer is
in total control of where it goes next
all right you heard it here first of the
King the build-up was epic he's got
something good I don't even know what it
is y'all so I'm just telling y'all right
now I don't even know please check that
out man King Stach support please y'all
click the video stop just eating off the
tweet clicks if you don't you know I'm
saying I'm almost a on and I gotta be on
abhi petty I gotta be Lord petty I just
don't like how you're not giving my man
that king of statue though because he's
putting it out there the production is
live this is all him this is his project
I don't have no ends when I sit there
and I'm amazed like to see what he doing
and then of course my brother saw his
debut packs he's out there he's
microphone controlling he's doing his
thing
I'm just smile I'm in the back of smile
and I'm like yeah
there you go that's the takeover tickets
go cuz next week I'm going back in the
shabby out of them fact you gotta be to
shame me out of the yes we gotta do a
poll soft gotta stop being more cockney
told incognito the best way to solve
telephone people we want to you can find
you can find me on Twitter Lord saw ILP
of course be excitement on our Xbox Live
in PS and in guys when I tell you that
the content is going to be coming at you
fast and furious and ready the internet
here has not been great not been able we
have not been able to upload the 50 gigs
of content that we it is insane you guys
might be saying oh it's Cognito doing
all the interviews no you're gonna be
seeing my 800 so I was out here baby
chuckling and I ready yeah we did
honestly man when I tell you that we
hustled and we ran up and down that show
floor for three days straight we're not
joking like will you hit everything
there's a lot of stuff coming so look
out for it alright you already know what
it is and of course Lord Carlito here
the gaming ninja another pack
successfully in the books one more day
left but we had to talk to the people
this is fun shout the King for actually
making me do this get out your system in
the Attic we miss you brother y'all
ready room and thing is gonna be late
and when we come out we hit your foot it
everybody enjoyed your Saturday night
turn up Sunday the Lord's travel back
next week will return solve my be host
you gotta co-host
also again another executive move on a
king
hey we gonna definitely move forward it
may be a puffball situation it may not
be a buckwild situation but let me tell
you guys thank you anybody that's in
this chat anybody that's watching this
live room thank you thank you Willa
validation absolutely and on that note
we are re everybody enjoy your Sunday
peace